There's nothing scarier than the truth.
If you're a true believer
in the paranormal
then you likely know this couple,
Ed and Lorraine Warren.
And if you don't
you might have heard about movies
they inspired
like The Conjuring, Annabelle,
The Haunted, The Nun
The Amityville Horror,
The Haunting in Connecticut.
Their story spaned a cinematic universe
that rivals the success of...
well, the main one you think of
when I say the words
cinematic universe.
But this isn't the first time
their stories are told.
So how did this very specific,
very scary Conjuring universe...
become so successful?
Ed Warren was a demonologist.
Lorraine Warren was a trance medium...
better known as a clairvoyant.
Together, for decades, they were
paranormal investigators...
looking to some of the most famous
occurrences of the occult...
all over the world.
“This was just another haunted house,
and we didn't even realize...
that six people had been murdered
in that house: The DeFoe family.”
They investigated hauntings
of small children
demonic presences and
even a werewolf...
which is all detailed on their
incredible website
that has case files for some of their
most famous investigations.
This one in particular was no joke.
As Lorraine explains in this featurette
from Warner Brothers.
“This is the worst thing.”
“I'm not going to—I'm not going
to stare at it, though.”
“That has done bad harm
on a lot of people.”
Now, why would they have a creepy doll
on display like that?
Well, after the Warrens
closed a case
they would often take
the haunted objects back home
in order to keep them safe
from the public.
They kept them in their basement
in Monroe, Connecticut...
which went on to become an occult museum
considered to be...
“The most haunted area in the world.”
“That's what I would say.”
“I would say that it is.”
Without even mentioning Hollywood
I think anyone would say that their story has
all of the ingredients to make
an awesome movie.
But when Hollywood has tackled their cases...
most of the films have left the Warrens
out of the narrative.
Like there are roughly
30 Amityville movies
about this haunted house where in 1976
the Warrens and their crew investigated...
and took this ghost photo of a boy
who had been murdered there.
But none of these films were
specifically about the couple.
The Warrens were portrayed
on the small screen
in 1991’s The Haunted—
which can I just say,
[chef’s kiss with Italian hands] excellent title.
But they weren't put at the center
of any story until 2013’s...
The Conjuring.
The movie that changed everything
for the horror genre.
And that's not hyperbole.
The Conjuring is the highest grossing
horror franchise of all time.
But before we dive into the
boring financials of the universe...
let's first talk about why
The Conjuring worked.
The trailer for the film lays on
the concept of candor really thick.
“It's not a haunting.”
“It's not a possession.”
“But the truth.”
It was marketing gold,
of course.
But the truth was also incredibly important
to the creative team.
Lorraine Warren was a consultant on the film
and she became close friends
with her onscreen counterpart.
The subjects of the film,
the Perron family
who were haunted and eventually possessed
by a witch named Bathsheba...
are still very much alive
and have given
chilling interviews with Warner Brothers.
Like in this other featurette.
“I doubt very much that
I will be willing to see the film...
for the same reason I'm unwilling
to ever go back to the house.”
Jesus Christ.
Of course, creative liberties
are always taken
but the team had a lot of reverence
for the truth.
Reflecting on the film recently
with Entertainment Weekly.
Director James Wan said that
one of the things he wanted to do
is to treat it like it's straight forward drama
and not even a horror film.
And that's pretty clear because the story is heartfelt...
the acting is sincere and grounded,
and it was masterfully shot.
This is true of pretty much every movie
in The Conjuring universe.
They all try to keep an emotional story at the center...
whether it's romantic, familial,
or friendship...
and they all have extremely creative scares.
And if you have beef
with that statement
then you can take it up
with my electric bill.
Because after rewatching the movies
to make this video...
I have not been able to sleep with light off for days
and I really wish I was joking.
But I am so scared.
The first 10 minutes of The Conjuring
are primarily focused on
building out who the Warrens are
through the Annabelle case.
You know the one about
the extremely haunted doll
that Lorraine was talking about earlier?
“That harmed a lot of people.”
It looks a little different in the movie...
but it's a great way to establish that
Ed and Lorraine are accomplished
paranormal investigators...
while giving the audience
a quick hit of scares before
moving on
to the actual subject of the movie:
The Perron family.
But also plants seeds to show
that there are more stories
to tell in this world.
Like in The Conjuring, we get
glimpses of Annabell.
In The Conjuring 2, we get
a few moments with the zoetrope
of the Crooked Man.
In Annabelle Creations
we get a photo that briefly features the nun.
It's like the films are constantly referencing
their deep archive of case files.
But of course, no device is more beautiful
for building out a universe
than the occult museum.
It's like the Infinity Stones times a million.
And the film's creators knew this.
Director James Wan even said
that it occurred to them early on.
“There's already a superhero universe.”
“Why couldn't they do that in the horror world?”
When you think of your favorite horror films
they're often continuously running franchises.
People liked Halloween.
So let's give them more Halloween.
Same with Nightmare on Elm Street.
But not The Conjuring.
One year after its release,
Annabelle came out...
giving a feature length treatment
to the minor story
at the beginning of The Conjuring.
That would be like if Scream
was followed up by a spin-off
of the history of Drew Barrymore's character.
Who—spoiler alert for a
27-year-old-movie—
dies in the first 15 minutes of the film.
But of course, the filmmakers didn't do that.
They just did Scream 2,
which followed characters
from Scream 1 on a
new slashing adventure.
Like the MCU, The Conjuring
expands the universe around its characters.
The Warrens, Annabelle,
and the Nun...
all have their own standalone francises
which have connective tissue across movies
but then they'll also crossover.
Like how the Warrens show up
in the final Annabelle movie.
The strength of doing a shared universe
is that you get to bounce around
with completely different vibes.
But there's one more thing that
makes the Conjuring universe stand out
as a massive success.
They make a huge bang for their buck
thanks to their reasonably small budgets.
This is because they're often
haunted house films.
And when you're mainly using one location...
you have fewer variables, more control,
and can shoot way faster.
And they're not just successful
by horror metrics.
Compare the return on investment
of the budget versus the box office
to other shared universes...
and the results are impressive,
to say the least.
And Warren passed away in 2006.
Lorraine Warren passed away in 2019.
In their 61 years of marriage
the couple investigated over 10,000 cases.
With no sign of The Conjuring universe's
popularity slowing down...
there are still so many stories left to tell.
Hey, it's me!
The ghost that's come out to haunt you
forever and ever.
Before I do that, I was told to
read this card.
So let's see what it says here, huh?
First off, it says:
Thank you so much for watching this video.
I have no idea what that means, but...
anyways, weird,
it also says...
if you were to go to Vox.com/givenow
and become a contributor...
I might not be forced to haunt you
for all eternity.
You'd also receive fun extras like
a newsletter from Vox journalists.
Apparently this is the best way
to support our journalism
and make sure that Vox stays free.
Also, it'll keep me from hovering
around your room in the dead of night.
So if you want to see more videos like this
and get some sleep...
go to vox.com/givenow.
See you in the next one.
Or tonight.
In your bedroom.
If you don't contribute
I'll be there and I'm going
to haunt you.
Beware.
Alright, bye!